[Music]
hey everyone this is keith.weiler with
little light ministries on another
episode of i've got a question today's
question is how can i identify
unsuitable media
so to start let's turn to a passage that
may be familiar to you it's in
philippians chapter 4 and verse 8. i'd
like to read it to you and then we'll
start to break it down
it says finally brethren whatever things
are true whatever things are noble
whatever things are just whatever things
are pure whatever things are lovely
whatever things are of good report if
there is any virtue and if there is
anything praiseworthy meditate on these
things so let's start to break this down
a little bit if we took these principles
one by one and apply them to our media
choices i think it would make things
easier the first one is
whatever things are true
what things are you watching
are they true or are they false things
do they promote the truth or do they
promote air that's one principle that we
can use to help guide our media choices
the next one talks about things that are
noble in other words are these
high
choices are they things that are
enabling are they things that lift our
thoughts higher are they things that
draw us
essentially closer to god so if they are
not doing that then that's something
else that we would want to stay away
from
the next things are on here is whatever
things are just are the things that are
you're watching righteous do they
promote justice do they promote
righteousness
the next one on the list is whatever
things are pure
we want to watch things that are that
are keeping our minds pure keeping our
minds clean
whatever things are lovely things that
are of beauty or beautiful those are the
types of things according to this
passage if we apply these principles
that we should be watching if there is
any virtue and if there is anything
praiseworthy meditate on these things so
when we're given this list we're
supposed to think about
all of these things and evaluate our
choices by these principles you know is
it true is it just is it noble is it
pure is it lovely
will it bring out a good report will it
be virtuous
and i think if we used that as our guide
we would probably watch
far fewer things because very few
measure up to that even the news in a
lot of cases doesn't measure up to this
list now let's talk about this in
practical terms take the news and for
example the eternals is the news true
sometimes it is sometimes it's not you
have to learn to filter that is the
eternals true no it's completely
fabricated what about just or noble or
pure or lovely well the news may have
some of those things sometimes but a lot
of the news is actually bad news what
about the eternals are there any things
in it that are lovely or
noble or just or virtuous
maybe some
but by and large
i would say it doesn't qualify if you
compare it to the word of god it's
actually a very gnostic film
so
you have to learn to discern and you
have to evaluate things by the word of
god and use that as your criteria for
saying should i watch this or or not
obviously the news most of it is bad
news you don't want to fill your mind
with a whole bunch of murder stories
every day so be very careful on what you
let into your mind and what you're
keeping up on and what you're looking
into there's another principle i'd like
to read to you and it's found in psalm
101 3 it says this i will set nothing
wicked before my eyes but i hate the
work of those who fall away it shall not
cling to me
is what you're watching wicked
if it is that's an unsuitable media
choice what things are wicked well
things that are against god or god's law
those things would be wicked because
they're full of sin so we don't want to
just fill our minds with things that are
full of sin
or will teach us how to sin because that
would lead us astray
we don't want to cloud our minds with
those kind of things so
bottom line one simple principle i think
that you if you can take one thing away
from this video
it's this
will it draw me closer to god or will it
draw me away
if we were to live by that our media
choices i think would drastically change
[Music]
i hope that helps i hope that uh you
will share this video we hope that
you're enjoying them please let us know
in the comments below and you know share
it with somebody who may have the same
question as you and check out some of
our other videos as well that are
answering people's questions we'll see
you next time thanks for watching
[Music]
you